welcome back to a brand new year are you
excited or what i know kat and emily
should be considering i didn't crush
them yet for their guest host jokes that
were in my absence
unlike greg when he sits in this chair i
don't need a booster right now that's
right cultural reference that's newer
than 40 years old
you won't get that with greg gutfeld is
greg tied up naked with duct tape over
his mouth dumped in the girl's locker
room wait no that was him in high school
do you think greg is missing us right
now should we call him gigantic greg
actually from now on i will not be
[Laughter]
yeah yeah laugh it up
yeah so while they were yakking it up at
my expense i spent the last eight days
in one bed you know i usually prefer
eight different beds each night like
wilt chamberlain
but i was sick while i tested negative
on kovid i tested positive on everything
else i'm pretty sure i had the flu the
cold zika ebola
but what do you expect when you borrow
one of michael loftus's jackets
who mugged a rodeo clown
it looks like your shirt had a triple
bypass
i'm not kidding that thing harbors more
bacteria than a port authority toilet
thanks for that single laugh but thank
god thank god i made it through and i
wouldn't miss it for the world because
what a year we have planned i'm an
optimist and i see great things again
and not just when i look in the mirror
the best sign watching the legacy media
realize that they're screwed and you
know things are bad in 2022 when they're
still reliving 2021. here they are
gearing up for their version of conflict
christmas otherwise known as january 6th
2.0 yeah it's as if the only thing that
can save their crippled cabled network
is the ghost of president's past santa
trump
you see there's bit of an informal
network of reporters who've been through
it that day and are still coping with
that leaning on each other talking to
each other
there's a bit of an informal network of
reporters who've been through it that
day and are still coping with that who
are leaning on each other and talking to
each other and we're all still dealing
with that and feeling like we need to
convey to others how serious it was
yeah because only you guys thought it
was serious you jackasses
please everyone thought it sucked but
unlike you they're not trying to turn a
profit off it
but oh our nation's brave journalists
are still processing it like it was a
price surge and responsibly raised
chicken
yes they're taking a riot where the only
unnatural death was from a cop shooting
an unarmed woman and making it out to be
worse than 9 11. and it hurts that
they're still coping while everyone saw
it for what it was an ugly event that
came and went but cnn can't let go they
need to convey to others how serious it
was
for them
because they're the real victims
and why because reporting what actually
happened didn't scare enough people
and much like loftus's body spray
the ginned-up hysteria has long worn off
and all that's left is the stench
so what's left for cnn besides uh to
catch a predator reboot
they got the
stars they have to create a distraction
look at this guy wearing a viking hat
he's part of the unarmed insurrection
that no one has been charged with
insurrection 4. he's so scary he needed
a halloween costume but yeah it's the
journalists who are the real victims
here he wrote for poynter then in
january last year you said sometimes i'm
fine sometimes i want to sob for hours
sometimes i just want to sleep so that
sounds to me like trauma that sounds
like ptsd
do you feel like you still experience
that
i do think so to a certain extent is
that true for you as well
well you know i've had an experience in
my life with a really bad car accident
where i was diagnosed with ptsd and i've
been really grateful for this as i've
been dealing with january 6th to know
the signs of ptsd exactly because i've
been through treatment
you know i know what it is they're all
suffering from ptsd a disorder usually
experienced by military veterans and
actual violent crime victims you know
the people whose complaints the press
normally ignores
if these journalists are victims then so
is jesse smollette
they're hoaxing a hate crime against
themselves
and yet here they are demanding
compassion
something that was strangely missing
when dozens of americans were dying in
the riots that they the media at cnn
ignored back when everything was mostly
peaceful they hid those violent details
like the secret service hides joe
biden's car keys
so the media now appropriates the pain
of real victims
just like when they blame the terror
attack and waukesha on a suv
they certainly didn't feel this way when
violence rampaged through nearly two
dozen major cities led by libs perhaps
it's because they were far removed from
the disruption
destruction
that they papered over
see that's why it's the soldiers who get
ptsd not the people who sent them to war
but you can't blame them for trying the
polling has shown the country moved on
from cnn's latest fetish
at least the one that's legal
yes the public sees the republicans
moving in the right direction while it's
the dems who keep sinking like an iphone
dropped in a toilet
now i don't know if the republicans have
any answers since when do any
politicians these days like the maroon 5
catalog i pretty much hate them all
but anything is better than what the
dems are serving it's 2022 but it's
dressed up now as 2021. i might have
that backwards
inflation
covid crime it's a bottomless pit with
spikes at the bottom emily
[Laughter]
and that explains cnn all going all in
on january 6th and you could see right
through it like a miley cyrus tube top
it's also obvious
maybe january 6 will be the diversion we
need to save us from our own casual
dismissal of the suffering incurred
under democrat rule in 2021. maybe if we
focus on january 6 america won't look at
every single day other than that where
cnn dismissed your pain as deserved
where victims of persecution deserved it
and where law enforcement was worse than
the thugs they tried to protect you from
meanwhile they covered for the screwed
up anchors their political relatives and
their deviant producers
in 2021 cnn did more covering up of the
news than actual covering of the news so
i get it for cnn january 6
it really is their christmas
oh so they did kill james van der beek
there you are hey
i got you something what christmas was
last week oh no this is for january 6.
i got at the cnn gift shop in the
therapy section
oh you shouldn't have
oh my god a brian stelter doll
i love it i know you would and it comes
with accessories
terrible
so blame anger hysteria division they
all make great stocking stuffers and cnn
santa is here to say that it's you who
are naughty and them who are nice piece
of advice don't sit on his lap
listen to that crazed applause
let's welcome tonight's guest he's so
british even his crumpets have a stiff
upper lip author and political
commentator douglas murray
[Music]
she's skilled at leading cheers riding
steers and down in beers outnumbered
co-host emily compagno
and when he's on set that frees up one
extra bed at the homeless shelter
the loftistparty.com founder michael
loftus
and her new year's resolutions are all
court-ordered
that was a hefty laugh i think maybe
because it's true ah fox news
contributor cat tim
all right wow
so anyway uh i do think i'm the real
victim here i've been sick i just got
back douglas uh thank you for the kind
uh card and the i think that was you
that sent me the card i don't remember
sending anything
i don't remember caring
[Laughter]
you just made me spit
can you blame cnn for not moving on this
is kind of like the only thing they got
left at this point it's true is
something particularly unpleasant and
ugly about journalists talking about
themselves like you know it used to be a
rule in journalism that you just never
talked about yourself like right that
reporters didn't say you know the
stories about me
you reported on what you saw i i know
war correspondents long term war
correspondents who don't do this
they just don't do it
they don't turn up and tell everyone
else they've got ptsd from it and uh
presenters don't diagnose ptsd live on
air right
that's so true
you know
so no i mean of course they don't want
to let go of it they're the heroes yes
they're the brave truth tellers they've
always wanted to be since they first saw
all the president's men yes that's so
true whenever you can make yourself the
protagonist why wouldn't you isn't that
why you know that's it's not why you're
wearing that uh
mutant
uh mutants
come on you can do it pull it out that
mutant everything
it's like it's like somebody who had one
of those zipper surgeries
but you had your pecs removed
i got this uh from billy gibbon's
dumpster
from zz top there you go
uh
um
should cnn maintain focus on this are we
not focusing they should keep going they
need to uh shine a spotlight on this
it's all about me i'm a victim here's
what they like to do uh the lefty uh
pinko commies over at cnn and the left
they have this like whole uh cry bully
mentality they act like oh it's
unprecedented it's never happened before
i'm really i've been traumatized and
someone needs to pass a law and the
government needs to come in like it's so
horrible to watch and it's so
predictable and boring like they act
like the the capital has never been
uh attacked before i think it was bombed
it was bombed in the 80s it was bombed
in the 70s there was a shooting in the
50s
in 1812
still pissed about that one buddy
yeah i'm glad you brought that up yeah
yeah i'm glad you never forget never
forget
but you know what the other thing that
they're denying and this is the thing
that gets me ticked off because it
requires everybody to go through this
exercise of condemning it
we aren't like the mostly peaceful riots
we said
those are freaking riots and the thing
that happened january 6 sucked that was
a riot
no one's denying that but what cnn
pretends is that they pretend that they
didn't deny the real violence and that
they're the only ones talking about this
and so in order to buy into this lie you
have to only you have to have like
chemically induced amnesia you have to
be exclusively focused on this or you
didn't give it enough attention right
right the new york times editorial board
said quote every day is january 6th yes
so yes you're either obsessed with it or
it's not enough i think the interesting
thing as as they diagnose themselves
with trauma and the like is that you
would think if they experienced this
absolutely horrible day and have
resulting psd ptsd from it that they
would empathize with the millions of
americans who went through these years
of violence in these last couple years
with the 500 families that lost a loved
one to homicide to gun shots in dc last
year or here in new york city 800 in
chicago the guy who was beaten to death
in front of his two children while
hanging christmas lights the list goes
on of the families across america that
have been absolutely ripped apart by
homicide by by skyrocketing uh crime
statistics and by urban centers that
have absolutely imploded you would think
these guys would exercise some empathy
and say yes yes i have a modicum of
understanding of how that felt so let me
report on it let me lift up and amplify
your voices but instead they're just
absolutely ignoring what voters really
care about which is their safety and
their livelihood you know to boil down
that very long answer to something
sorry think about this those
spent more time talking about their ptsd
than
ashley babbitt
that is a person who was shot dead
unarmed woman and i don't remember cnn's
talking about the ptsd of her family or
anybody there who saw her get killed
unarmed that that's
that's uh that's a lot to digest let's
go to cat timf
[Laughter]
dad what's going on with you other
things
you got sick too but you were so i'm not
going to ask you what you had because
it's none of my business i had omicron
and ptsd yes i guess if that's what it
is like sometimes i'm fine sometimes i'm
sobbing yes that's normal that's my life
how i live yes
i just hope that they're lying i hope
it's not true that there's not really
this group of people that meets up to
hang out and talk about january 6.
what do you do you go to happy hour
like chips and glock and talk about it i
don't believe them and i hope for their
sake that it's not true because that
that makes me sad yeah and the thing is
ptsd is real real i i there's no doubt
that they were shaken up about some of
the things that happened but this is an
appropriation that like going back to
what douglas said despite being british
he is correct
i forgot see i went on the side now i
forgot the point i was going to make
appropriating trauma appropriating drama
is something that our press is a it's a
modern phenomenon yeah it's a modern
phenomenon to talk about yourselves
because you might actually get a book
deal out of it too you know a gig at cnn
yeah or a gig at cnn you're not supposed
to want ptsd no you're not yet don't you
remember the the cops testifying this is
a whole new thing yeah it has to be oh i
was so shook oh i got ptsd like they had
those cops testifying and every single
one of them cried yeah like what and by
the way i didn't expect it and they were
pushing and then i was pushing back
but you know we got to move on but you
know but you know that's that was the
first time i saw cnn sympathetic to the
police
right
because it was it was something that
they could nail an administration for
all right up next crime is liberal
seeking alternatives making them seem
more like conservatives
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else